[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم قال الامين العام لحزب الله حسن
نصر الله ان دماء شهداء القنيطره تعبر عن
امتزاج الدم الايراني اللبناني على الارض
السوريه وتعبر عن وحده المصير واضاف نصر
الله في خطاب تابين ضحاياه في القنيطره ان
قواعد الاشتباك مع اسرائيل قد تغيرت الان
حسب تعبيره نتوقف مع هذا الخبر نناقشه في
محورين ما هو الدور الذي يلعبه حزب الله
وايران في الجولان السوري وهل تغير قواعد
الاشتباك يعني وجود قرار بتوسيع المواجهه
مع
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل لاول مره يعلن حزب الله عن عبر
امينه العام حسن نصر الله عن وجود لمسلح
في الجولان السوري نصر الله كان يتحدث في
احتفال لتابين قتلاه الذين سقطوا في قصف
اسرائيلي خلال اجتماع لهم في القنيطره
السوريه بحضور جنرال ايراني تحدث نصر الله
عما سماه تغير قواعد الاشتباك مع اسرائيل
بعد استهدافها لقادته في
القنيطره انت بدك تنسى اسرائيل انساها نحن
ما بنقدر ننساها هكذا اكد حسن نصر الله
خلال خطابه عصر الجمعه تعليقا على استهداف
اسرائيل لافراد من حزبه بالقنيطره السوريه
ثم رد الحزب بعد ايام في مزارع شبعه خطاب
يستدعي بريق الحزب المقاوم بعد ان نالت
منه مشاركه معلنه في القتال الدائري في
سوريا الى جانب نظام الاسد قال نصر الله
ان من قتل من كوادره بالاضافه الى الجنرال
الايراني كانوا يبعدون سته كيلومترات عن
الشريط الحدودي وبينهم وبين الجانب
الاسرائيلي مقاتل جبهه النصره لكن ما لم
يجب عنه الخطاب المطول ما الذي كان يفعله
هؤلاء مع الجنرال الايراني في الجولان
السوري المحتل في المقابل شن الرجل هجوما
حادا على جبهه النصره السوريه متهما اياها
بالتحالف مع اسرائيل ومذكرا بادراجها على
قوائم ما يوصف بالارهاب دوليا لم يعد سرا
تدخل حزب الله الصريح في الازمه السوريه
بجانب النظام ضد الثائرين عليه لكنها
المره الاولى التي يعلن فيها حسن نصر الله
عن تواجد حزبه في الجولان تحديدا فهل
يتواجد تحسبا لاسرائيل ام لجبهه النصره
الحزب لا يواري دعمه لنظام الاسد وله
مبررات ينسبها دائما الى مقاومه المشروع
الاسرائيلي في المنطقه وهو يتباه الان
ببراعه رده على مصرع بعض جنوده في سوريا
لكنه لم يقل لماذا لا يرد على انتهاكات
اسرائيليه متكرره لسماء سوريا وارضها تلك
التي لا يعلق عليها نظام حليفه الاسد
كثيرا رغم انه رفع سقف التهديد لاسرائيل
عاليا نحن في المقاومه الاسلاميه في لبنان
لم تعد تعنينا اي شيء اسمه قواعد
اشتباك انا لا اعترف نحن لا نعترف بقواعد
اشتباك
انته ولا في مواجهه العدوان والاغتيال ما
في قواعد
اشتباك ولم نعد نعترف بتفكيك الساحات
والميادين فسر نصر الله كلامه السابق بان
الجبهه اصبحت واحده من الناقوره في لبنان
الى القنيطره بالجولان فهل تحمل تلك
الكلمات قرارا ضمنيا بتوسيع نطاق المواجهه
في حال اندلاع حرب مع اسرائيل ام انها لا
تعدو تصعيدا دعائيا في الحفل وفي كلمه
امين عام حزب الله ملمح اخر جدير بالتوقف
كانت طهران حاضره على مستوى رئيس لجنه
الامن القومي في مجلس الشورى الايراني
علاء بروجردي لا غرابه فثم قتيل بارز من
الحرس الثوري في الهجوم الاسرائيلي على
القنيطره ما اعتبره نصر الله امتزاجا ل دم
الايراني اللبناني على الارض السوريه في
تجاهل متجدد من زعيم حزب الله لانهار من
دماء السوريين تسيل منذ اربع سنوات بيد
جبهته
المقاومه لمناقشه موضوع حلقتنا ينضم الينا
من بيروت الكاتب الصحفي قاسم قصير ومن
عمان الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ياسر الزعتره
اهلا بضيفي الكريمه سيد قاسم نبدا معك
فيما يتعلق ب ما جاء في كلمه الامين العام
لحزب الله وتوصيفه لما جرى في
القنا اللبناني على الارض السوريه في
تج زعيم حزب الله للسوريين
تسيل سم
قصير نبدا معك فيما
يتعلق اللبناني على
الارض سم
قصير
عام 2008 حتى اليوم نفذ وحاول تنفيذ
العديد من العمليات التي تستهدف
الاسرائيليين سواء في فلسطين المحتله او
في على الحدود او في مناطق في كل انحاء
العالم سائرا للحاج اماد مغنيه ول بقيه
اخوانه ط عن سؤالي اجبته ماذا عن سؤالي
ايه س ساجيب عن سؤالك اما الم حسب
معلوماتي ان حزب الله عندما نفذ عمليه
مزارع شبعه كان مستعدا لاقصى الاحتمالات
وتم استنفار كل عناصر حزب الله في الجنوب
وفي لبنان استعدادا لاحتمال حصول الحرب
لانه كان هناك تخوف ان يكون هدف العمليه
في منطقه القنيطره ان تستدرج اسرائيل حزب
الله الى حرب شامله لذلك حزب الله استعد
لهذه المساله ونفذ العمليه بشكل واضح وفي
منتصف النهار واستهدف قافله اسرائيليه
كبرى وكان هناك توقع ان اسرائيلين سينفذون
رد كبير على هذه العمليه وفقا للتحليلات
او الاحتمالات ل هل البوصله الاسرائيليه
عفوا هل البوصله حزب الله مازالت متوجهه
بالاساس لاسرائيل ام البوصله الان موجهه
لاخماد الثوره في سوريا وابقاء نظام الاسد
لا انا برايي يعني ما جرى في مزارع شبعه
وما يجري ما جرى من عمليات سابقه استهدفت
الاسرائيليين في منطقه مزارع شبعه منذ عده
اشهر وفي على الحدود اللبنانيه فلسطينيه
تؤكد ان حزب الله يستهدف اسرائيل وحتى ان
دفاع حزب الله عن الرئيس بشار الاسد او عن
سوريا ليس حبا ببشار الاسد او بالنظام
السوري انما لان سوريا كانت مقر وممر
للمقاومه اللبنانيه والفلسطينيه وان ذهاب
سوريا لقوى معاديه للمقاومه وعادله لمشروع
المقاوم ليست في مصلحه المقاومه انا
والدليل ان وجود جبهه النصره على حدود دون
ان تقوم بعمليات تستهدف الاسرائيلين حزب
عن جبه النصره اسال هنا ضيفي ياسر زعتره
السيد نصره تكلم ما وصفهم بحلف
الاسرائيليين والامريكيين
والتكفيريين الا يحمل اتهام السيد نصر
الله وحزب الله شيء من الوجاع عندما يتعلق
عن طبيعه دور هذه المنظمات في علاقتها
باسرائيل
يعني انا في تقديري هذا ضرب من الهراء
الذي يردد الخطاب الايراني الحلف التكفيري
الصهيوني هذا ك كلام فارغ الان وبشار
الاسد يستجدي العالم ويستجدي امريكا
ويستجدي الغرب وهذا الكلام يرد على لسان
حسين امير عبد اللهيان من اجل التحالف ضد
هذه المنظمات للقضيه في هذا الواقع وجهان
الوجه الاول هو الوجه الايراني الذي يعتبر
بشار الاسد هو الركن الاساسي في مشروع
التمدد وبالتالي من الضروري الحفاظ عليه
الوجه الاخر هو الوجه الاسرائيلي الصهاينه
منذ منذ بدايه الثوره ومذ عسكره الثوره
اخذوا قرارا بانه لا بد من اطاله امد
المعركه من اجل تحويل سوريا الى ثقب اسود
يستنزف جميع اعداء الكيان السوني ومن
ضمنهم ايران وحزب الله فضلا عن تركيا
والربيع العربي بشكل عام وبالتالي هم
يعتقدون ان بقاء بشار الاسد في سوريا
ضعيفا وهشا ومنهك افضل بكثير من وجود قوى
لا يمكن السيطره عليها الذي يقول ان جبهه
النصره عميله للاحتلال او تتعاون مع
الاحتلال انا في تقديري هذا يستخف بالعقل
الانساني وليس فقط بالعقل الاسلامي لكن
هذه القو وجبهه النصره من ضمنها وكل القوى
في الساحه السوريه ليس لديها مصلحه في
الوقت الراهن بفتح اشتباك مع الكيان
الصهيوني وبالتالي هي لديها مشكله مع مع
مع النظام وتشتبك مع النظام ومع ذلك الذي
يحمي هذه النظام والذي حرم الثوار من
السلاح النوعي القادر على حسم المعركه
وضغط على العالم اجمع من اجل حرمانهم من
السلاح النوعي هو الكيان الصهيوني وبضغطه
على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والغرب
وبالتالي الحديث عن تعاون بين هاتين
الفئتين هذا ضرب من الوراء بالعكس كل
دوائر البحث والتحليل الاسرائيليه تتحدث
عن ان الخطر الاكبر الذي يوجه يواجه
الكيان الصهيوني في المرحله المقبله هي
هذه الحركات الجهاديه التي لا يستطيع احد
ان يسيطر عليها بينما يمكن السيطره على اي
مجموعات اخرى تتبع الولي الفقيه وما شابه
نعم بعد فاصل قصير سوف نتابع ايضا فيما
جاء في تصريحات الامين العام لحزب الله
السيد حسن صلا بشان تغير قواعد الاشتباك
مع اسرائيل ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش تصريحات امين عام حزب الله بشان
تغير قواعد الاشتباك مع اسرائيل سيد قاسم
قصير فيما يتعلق بهذه الجمله تغير قواعد
الاشتباك وما خلفته رد فعل في داخل لبنان
وصفت هذا التصريح بانه امعان في استفراد
حزب الله بمساله القرار في لبنان ولكن
بعيدا عن هذه المساله عندما يتكلم السيد
نصر الله
تغيير قواعد الاشتباك تغيير قواعد
الاشتباك يعني التملص من القرار الدولي
1701 وبالتالي اذا كان هذا القرار صحيحا
لماذا يضرب حزب الله في اطار الالتزام
بهذا القرار
اذا يعني هناك فرق ما بين قرار 1701
وقواعد الاشتباك القرار 1701 هو الذي اتى
بعد حرب 2006 والذي ادى الى مجيء القوات
الدوليه او تعزيز القوات الدوليه في جنوب
لبنان وانتشار الجيش اللبنان لاني في جنوب
لبنان وخروج المسلح لحزب الله العلني من
مناطق جنوب الليطاني اما موضوع قواعد
الاشتباك فهي بدات عام
1993 بعد اغتيال الشهيد سيد عباس الموسوي
ومن ثم بما سمي تفاهم نيسان 1996 الذي قضى
بعدم استهداف المدنيين اللبنانيين مقابل
عدم استهداف المدنيين اسرائيليين وبحصر
المعركه في الجبهه انا برايي ما قاله امين
عام حزب الله سيد حسن نصر الله هو يعني
اعاده فتح المجال لقوى المقاومه لاستهداف
الاسرائيليين في اي مكان في العالم وان
هذا الموضوع اذا كان حزب الله يقوم به ولو
بشكل غير علني في سابقا هو سيقوم به الان
بدون ان يكون لديه مشكله لان اسرائيل
تستهدف كوادره وعناصره انا برايي ما قاله
استاذ حسن هو يهدف لنوع من كان يعني هذه
المساله لماذا قيم كلام السيد نصر الله
بان هناك فارق شاسع بين اللغه ومستوى
اللغه والوعود والوعيد الت جاءت في كلامه
وبين رد الفعل الذي قدم على اساس انه رد
فعل منضبط ومضبوط من حيث المكان والايقاع
الزمني لا انا ما ما جرى في مزارع شبعه هو
تم اختيار منطقه محتله طبعا حزب الله من
ناحيه حكمته في اداره الامور لا يريد جر
لبنان الى حرب واسعه في لحظه ما لكنه كان
مستعدا للحرب انا يعني اختيار مزارع شبعه
اولا لكي يرد على الذين يقولون انه لا
يستهدف قوات الاحتلال في مزارع شبعه وهي
موجوده ثانيا الوقائع الميدانيه والعمليه
في منطقه مزارع شبعه هناك قدره للمقاوم في
تنفيذ عمليات ثالثا الظروف التي يعني نفذت
فيها العمليه والوصول المقاومين الى تلك
المنطقه لان حزب الله اي عمليه لا يمكن
تنفيذها بكبسه زر هي تحتاج الى مقدمات
والى استعدادات عمانيه وميدانيه انا براي
حزب الله نفذ عمليه مزارع شبعه وهو مستعد
لاحتمال حصول حرب واسعه لكن يبدو ان
الاسرائليين الان لا يريدون الذهاب نحو
حرب واسعه سواء بسبب نعم سيد ياسر العاطره
عندما يتكلم سي نصر الله عن تغيير قواعد
الاشتباك اليس هذا دليل قوي على ان حزب
الله يفهم اللغه التي ترضع
اسرائيل يعني الكل يفهم اللغه التي تردع
اسرائيل وليس فقط حزب الله لكن حزب الله
منذ 2008 منذ اغتيال عماد مغنيه بل منذ
2006 منذ تفاهمات حرب نهايه حرب تموز
ووجود قوات اليونيفيل وهو يلتزم وحول
السلاح عمليا الى سلاح للحسم الداخلي وثم
عندما اندلعت الثوره السوريه نقله الى
السياق السوري وبدا يشارك في قتل الشعب
السوري قواعد الاشتباك التي يتحدث عنها في
تقديري هذه جزء من التقدير الايراني
للصراع في اي حاله من الاحوال هذه كلها
تدرس بناء على مصلحه الابقاء على بشار
الاسد في حاله وجد ان هذا سيخدم وجود بشار
الاسد سيجري تغيير قواعد الاشتباك لكن في
كل الذي جرى في مزارع شبعه هي عمليه
محدوده ومحدده فقط لا غير لماذا لم تحدث
على سبيل المثال ثارا لعماد مغنيه لماذا
ذهبوا الى الى الى الى ارجنتين وما الى
ذلك كان بوسعهم ان يفعلوا ذلك لكنهم ضمن
حسابات سياسيه لم يفعلوا الان في ظل الذي
جرى في في الجولان وهؤلاء كانوا ذهبوا
لاستهداف الشعب السوري وليس لاستهداف
الاسرائيلي الكل يعلم لماذا جاء حزب حزب
الله الى الى الى سوريا والكل يعرف لماذا
لماذا لا يحتفل حزب الله بالقتلى اكثر من
1000 قتيل يمرون هكذا مرور الكرام بينما
اقام الدنيا واقعد من اجل سته قتلوا في
الجولان الكل يدرك ان هذه اللعبه هي لعبه
تتعلق بالشان السوري على وجه التحديد
وبقناعة
وهذا المشروع مصاب بغرور وغطرسته القوه من
يستمع الى محمد صادق الحسيني قبل ايام في
قناه الميادين وهو يتحدث عن عبد الملك
الحوثي كسيد للجزيره العربيه وعن سيطره
ايران على البحر المتوسط وعلى البحر
الاحمر يدرك اي غرور قوه يتلبس هؤلاء
وبالتالي هؤلاء يستخدمون اسم فلسطين واسم
القدس في سياق ترفضه الامه مع اي بندقيه
توجه الى الا على انلا تتاجر بهذه القضيه
لما لما اشترته له الان وه سؤالي موجه
السيد قاسم قصير فيما يتعلق بهذه المساله
ايضا بعض من قرا السيد خطاب سيد نصر الله
واللغه المرتفعه في هذا الخطاب قال انما
جاءت وما حملته من مصطلحات كتغيير قواعد
الاشتباك وما جاء في هذا الخطاب انما ايضا
لم يجب على سؤال مهم كيف تم استهداف هذه
المجموعه في القنيطره ماذا عن الاختراق
الامني المخابراتي لحزب الله وهذه علامه
ضعف
كبيره يعني اولا بالجولان منطقه مفتوحه
وقدره الاسرائيليين على الوصول الى مراكز
مراكز سواء الجيش السوري او الشباب
المقاومين قدره مفتوحه انا براي الموضوع
ليس موضوع اختراق امني منطقه الجل منطقه
مفتوحه يوجد فيها قوات يوند ف يوجد فيها
جبهه النصره يوجد فيها جيش سوري ويوجد
فيها الاسرائيليون يطرون انا برايي يعني
مع احترامي للاستاذ ياسر الزعاتره الان هو
دائما يريد ان ياخذ المال كان الان نحن
نناقش المشروع الايراني والدور الايراني
نحن نناقش الصراع مع العدو اسرائيلي السيد
حسن نصر الله الان يقول نحن في صراع مع
عدو اسرائيلي منذ 2006 حتى اليوم نفذت
عشرات العمليات التي تستهدف الاسرائيليين
في كل انحاء العالم وفي على الحدود
اللبنانيه نفذت عمليتان الاولى في منطقه
مزارع شبعه قبل سنه تقريبا والثانيه على
الحدود اللبنانيه الفلسطينيه في مواجهه
دوريه اسرائيليه الراع مع العدو
الاسرائيلي سراع اساسي الذهاب الى سوريا
كان بهدف ابقاء خط امداد المق قاومه في
لبنان وفي فلسطين والان اصح يدرك قاس لو
الان ردت عفوا لو ردت الان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اذا تسمح لي تفضل تفضل ب 30
ثانيه يعني فقط انا اود يعني نحن اذا كنا
نريد ان نناقش المشروع الايراني في هذه
الحلقه انا ما عندي مانع يعني ننا سع
كلامك السد ياسر ز ولكن لو قرت الان عف قر
اسرائيلي معك وع المقاطعه لو قررت الان
اسرائيل ان تشن حرب شامله في لبنان وجزء
مهم من عناصر حزب الله الان متورطون في ما
يجري في سوريا هل يستطيع حزب الله ان يخوض
حرب الان حسب ما تكلم به سيد نصر الله في
خطابه يعني انا اود ان اطمئن الجميع ان
حزب الله لديه الاف ان لم يكن عشرات
الالاف من المقاتلين والمجاهدين المستعدين
الان لمواجهه اي عدوان اسرائيلي سواء
بالقدره الصاروخيه بالقدره التكتيكيه
بالقدره العمليه حتى ان الجبهه الداخليه
في لبنان الحمد لله اليوم هي في افضل
حالاتها منذ عام 2006 نحن الان في وضع
يشعر الانسان بالعزه
وبالكراك من يستطيع ان يفرض على
الاسرائيلي عدم التجرؤ بشن حرب يعني لو ان
اسرائيلي يريد ان يشن حرب الان كان هو اخذ
القرار بعد عمليه مزارع الشف لكن اسرائيلي
خائف من قوه حزب الله موضوع سوريا امر اخر
ينبغي مناقشته اذا كان هذا صحيحا او غير
صحيح لكن وجود حزب الله في سوريا ليس
الهدف منه حمايه بشار الاسد هو حمايه طريق
المقاومه واليوم المقاومه تتمتع بقدرات
قتاليه متميزه وبقدرات عسكريه والهدف
الاخير هو القدس وتحرير القدس وليس
استخدام القدس ك يعني عنوان او كح الهد
تحرير القدس وهنا سؤالي ايضا موجه لسيد
ياسر الزعاتره ما الذي يثبت او يدحض مساله
ان حزب الله فعلا
بوصلته قوميه عربيه لبنانيه باتجاه
اسرائيل وليس مجرد اداه في يد ايران
وبالتالي يفهم اي خطوه تتم في سوريا او في
لبنان او الحديث عن تغيير قواعد الاشتباك
او الحديث عن توسيع الجبه حتى تشمل
الجولان يدخل في حساب في اطار حسابات
ايرانيه وليس حسابات لبنانيه عربيه على
راسها حزب
الله يعني اولا السيد حسن نصر الله قال
مرارا انه جزء من مشروع الولي الفقيه
وبالتالي هو ياتمر باوامر الولي الفقيه
والكل يدرك والكل يعلم ان ان حزب الله لم
يكن مقتنعا في البدايه بالتدخل في الشان
السوري لكن اوامر صارمه جاءته من من طهران
بضروره التدخل الكل يدرك ان البوصله ليست
القدس وليست فلسطين عندما كانت كان قطاع
غزه يدك بالطيران الاسرائيلي 17 يوما وبعد
اتصال من خالد مشعل حتى تعطف السيد حسن
نصر الله واطلق تصريحا سياسيا لصالح
المقاومه في قطاع غزه و وفي ايران كذلك
اين كان هؤلاء وبالتالي من الواضح ان
هؤلاء لا مشروعهم ليس القدس وليس فلسطين
انما تستخدم القدس وتستخدم فلسطين في سياق
خدمه المشروع الايراني نحن لسنا ضد اي
بندقيه عندما كان يقاتل الا كنا نرفع له
القبعات لكن اليوم هو يستخدمها من اجل قتل
الشعب السوري من اجل تزكيه يقت
شع شكرا جزيلا لكما اشكر ضيفي من بيروت
الكاتب الصحفي قاسم قصير شكرا جزيلا لكما
ب تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء